i have an update today to start with
about an investigation that many of you
have been asking about going all the way
back to at least march of 2021 although
maybe further i remember certainly
talking about it in march of 2021
we've known that republican congressman
matt gates has been under investigation
for a number of different possible
crimes including uh sex trafficking
of underage girls and he lawyered up
with some of the best sex crime defense
attorneys in the uh in the country quite
frankly uh we've been expecting crimes
to be charged at some point and then
nothing has happened and many of you
have written to me and said david what's
going on now of course i know nothing
other than what is reported but we have
a new report from uh the middle of this
week
that matt gates ex-girlfriend
has testified to a grand jury
in the sex trafficking probe
suggesting that by all measures we are
getting closer to actual charges against
matt gates no guarantee but listen to
this report from nbc congressman matt
gates ex-girlfriend testified wednesday
before a federal grand jury
investigating him for sex crimes a major
development that suggests the doj may be
moving closer to indicting him the
ex-girlfriend whose name is being
withheld to respect her privacy has been
in talks for months with prosecutors
about an immunity deal can you imagine
his ex-girlfriend may be liable for
criminality and wants immunity
under a possible deal she would avoid
prosecution for obstruction of justice
in return for testifying in the
investigation into whether gates in 2017
had sex with a 17 year old female for
money
and whether months later he and others
violated a federal law prohibiting
people from transporting others across
state lines to engage
in prostitution
legal sources familiar with the case say
gates is being investigated for three
distinct crimes sex trafficking the 17
year old
violating the man act which prohibits
taking women across state lines for
prostitution
and obstructing police obstructing
justice
importantly gates has not been charged
with a crime gates has denied all
accusations saying he never paid for sex
he never had sex with a minor when he
was an adult he has called the
investigation
a witch hunt
the attorney for gate's ex-girlfriend
tim jansen declined to comment about the
case when he was spotted by a reporter
entering a courthouse in orlando with
the client
a department of justice spokesman
declined comment gates did not respond
to a request for comment the
investigation has lasted more than a
year it started when a former friend and
ally of gates tax collector joel
greenberg was charged with a host of
crimes from falsely smearing a political
rival as being a pedophile or pedophile
to change to cheating taxpayers in a
cryptocurrency scheme to sex trafficking
the same 17-year-old girl in gates
investigation greenberg has agreed to
plead guilty
and is cooperating with federal
investigators an important uh
aspect of the article here
is the serious nature of all of the
things matt gates is being investigated
for now we don't know what's going to
happen here this might lead to nothing
it's clearly not over
and it is matt gates own ex-girlfriend
who ultimately might provide the
testimony or might provide part of the
testimony we just don't know yet that
leads to very serious charges against
matt gates now what about removing matt
gates from the house of representatives
if he is charged
you can find a number of different uh
commentaries on this
it is typical that if members of the
house are charged with felonies
uh
that
they resign
they could be forced out
although whether the republican party
would be interested in doing that
particularly if they take over the house
of representatives before charges are
brought if they are there's a lot of
questions here but very very serious
charges
it's not over will he eventually be
charged we just don't know
but we could be just weeks away and i
know we've been saying that for a while
we could be weeks away
from finding out the answer to that
question
this weekend donald trump is going to be
speaking at a rally in arizona i will be
covering that rally one of the people
that is reportedly speaking alongside
donald trump at that rally is none other
than my pillow founder mike lindell
known to us as mike pillow lindell says
he's going to be one of the opening acts
at donald trump's january 15th rally in
arizona and expect 60 000 people to show
up why do i mention that well someone
who is going to be appearing alongside
the former president of the united
states is now claiming that he has
evidence to imprison
300 million americans for their actions
related to the 2020 election now you
might say wait david sir there are only
258 million adults in the us as of 2020.
and of the 258 million not all of them
not nearly all of them actually voted
doesn't matter pillow says he has
evidence to imprison 300 some million
people take a listen to what he had to
say this is the stuff of
insanity everything you're going to see
over these next seven months right get
rid of the machines you're going to see
the supreme court case coming out all
these great things everybody by the way
you can find more at frankspeach.com
i'll put that little out put that out
there there are so many i'm more
optimistic today than i have been
yesterday the day before that i'm on an
incline like this why because it's so
amazing all the things that we have we
already have all the pieces of the
puzzle and you talk about evidence we
had enough evidence to put everybody in
prison for life for 300 and some million
people uh wait we have that all the way
back to november december he has the
evidence to put 300 and some million
people in prison for life now before we
get back to that if you're wondering
about that scratchy weird voice that he
has i will mention that our friend
zachary patrizo from the daily beast
reported about that yesterday and says
my pillow ceo mike lindell
has come down with a severe case of
quote laryngitis
and he added in a comment to the daily
beast i can't get covid while citing his
consumption
of an unproven covid19 drug he probably
has coveted
is my understanding of that but more
importantly
evidence to imprison 300 something
million americans for life so if there's
only 258 million adults as of 2020 he's
talking about imprisoning
every adult who voted
every adult who didn't vote and then 42
million children
uh so things going
very very wrong for mike lindell in all
uh al all senses of the word
likely has coveted and again claims he
will be speaking at the trump rally this
weekend now i will be covering the trump
rally and many of you have written in
saying david please cover the trump
rally
others have said david don't cover the
trump rally uh i'm going to cover the
trump rally um it is fascinating you
know i
i just cover what is interesting and i
am fascinated to see
does the topic of vaccines come up at
the rally and does trump get booed trump
has been pushing the vaccines pretty
hard saying of course everybody needs
freedom but pretty significantly pushing
the vaccines is he going to get booed in
arizona for promoting the vaccines is
trump going to make an announcement
about 2024 is trump going to make any
announcements about support for
candidates in 2022 is mike lindell
really allowed to go and speak alongside
the former president given that he
almost certainly has coveted right now
uh and also is completely out of his
mind and it's humiliating that he's even
allowed near the president i mean it's
it's all completely crazy so i will be
covering the rally if it's not
interesting to you just don't watch it
um that that's my recommendation but i
will be live on
youtube
twitch
and facebook starting at 8 p.m eastern
saturday trump expected to speak at 9 00
pm meaning he will likely speak between
10 p.m and midnight i don't know he's
always historically he's always insanely
late to his speaking engagement so
that's going to be this weekend in the
meantime uh
we have no idea
what sort of evidence mike pillow claims
to have but i would guess that you and i
would not find it particularly
compelling make sure you're following me
on twitter at deepakman remember that we
are
still banned from facebook monetization
we're like five days into our 90-day ban
for what facebook's algorithm
misidentified as anti-vaccine content
from us
laughable claim
you all know
that we
are pro-vaccine because that's what the
science points to and we were reporting
on anti-vaxx alex jones and we have been
banned from facebook monetization for 90
days you can uh support us in that uh in
fighting that endeavor by signing up at
joinpakman.com and using the coupon code
f facebook that's facebook with two f's
f facebook you tell me what it means
we'll take a break we have a fantastic
program for you today glad you're with
us
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
welcome back to the show remember that
we are primarily funded by viewers and
listeners like you through the david
pakman show membership program you can
sign up at joinpackman.com
we are going to hear from some people in
the audience you can call in via discord
davidpakman.com
discord and we're going to start today
with clark from portland oregon clark
you're on the air
hi david um i was just wondering about
what your stance was on lowering the
voting age um
obviously you know teenagers pay taxes
many teenagers can be emancipated from
their parents and i was wondering what
your stance was on that and also if you
thought that ever be pushed through
congress i think there is not a desire
to have people be able to vote at age 16
or 17 which generally generally when
people say lower the voting age they
mean 16 or 17 is that what you have in
mind
yeah yeah i think that there is a case
to be made for that
i think it is widely seen as being
better for the left than the right
with the assumption that those 16 and 17
year olds are more likely to vote for
democrats than republicans i don't know
if that's actually true i think that
that's something that i would want to
find data on um i i am open to it i
think 17 more than 16 in theory the
truth is you know
the brain is not really fully formed at
that point in time we know more and more
about that it's part of the reason why
we're seeing some places push
smoking you know the age to buy
cigarettes looking at 21 instead of 18
i'm not necessarily looking to to lower
ages for things certainly not for for
driving and in fact as someone who got
my license when i was 16 and a half
and thinking back at my friend's driving
it it doesn't seem crazy to raise the
age to get your driver's license to 17
or 18. but i don't think that there's
much of an appetite among lawmakers to
lower the voting age
yes certainly it's just um it's tough to
see especially with all these um crazy
trumpists that are probably a lot less
educated than some 16 year olds in my
circle yeah um and seeing like oh like
these guys probably could make a much
better more informed voting decision
than a lot of people out there
there's no doubt that anecdotally there
are lots of 17 year olds that would much
be much more educated as voters than
many adults that vote regularly that's
without a doubt
well great thanks david i'm glad uh glad
to hear your opinion on that pleasure
thank you so much for the call there is
a clark asking about lowering the voting
age
let's go next to
dylan from massachusetts dylan you're on
the air
hi david can you hear me yes i can
okay perfect i'm in my car let me know
if there's any background noise
you know there is but we're going to try
to get get to the question
okay uh so what um if we were to see
some sort of national health care uh try
to believe and try to be implemented
what sort of model would you personally
want to see it uh modeled after oh that
that's really tough i mean here here's
the thing there's so many models that
work
you have to start with your priorities
and then work backwards so universal
access for me is a must
affordability for me is a must
and when you prioritize those two
it's conceivable
that quality may not be as high as you
want but obviously we we want all three
of these things and it's kind of like a
push pull with which uva reinhardt wrote
about in his in his most recent book
before he passed away so i think there
is a lot to look at
in the german system that's interesting
i think the nordic model is interesting
you know when people just say
medicare for all and forget about it
there's no debate to be had
i i don't necessarily agree with that i
don't think medicare for all is a
panacea and i think a lot of people who
say medicare for all they actually mean
a number of different configurations
that that could be possible um but i
have a long clip on this which looks at
i mean there's no one answer for me is
the point and one key issue as well is
my answer if we were to have one federal
system
might be different than if we say this
would be done at the state level
yeah i mean my personal opinion would be
look at canada or look at germany for
like a centralized versus a
decentralized system but yes
i think that depending on a number of
different factors specific to each
country
there are merits to all of these
different systems all of which are
better than the one we have in the
united states
interesting how do you think people
would react to the government taking a
more intrusive interest in public health
i think we know the answer to that part
of the country would welcome it and part
of the country would say that it's uh
fascism
do you remember when bill de blasio
tried to ban uh
certain like i think it was one gallon
or one liter jugs of soda from being
sold in like convenience stores wasn't
that bloomberg i don't i don't remember
de blasio doing it i remember bloomberg
doing it
maybe it might have been bloomberg i
just remember it was interesting to me
because i thought of all places new york
city would be okay with these sorts of
things and it just did not go well at
all well one of the things about that is
you you're kind of hurting sadly you're
hurting the poorer people because
typically you know when you buy
juice and soda whatever in larger
quantity you're paying less per ounce so
when you say no more 64 ounces only 32s
usually buying 232s is more expensive so
there was a real argument to be made
that it was disproportionately hurting
poor people which which is literally
true
yeah that's fair that's fair
i just i just
i see uh uh any sort of like efforts by
the government to make the public
healthier is is just not going super
well in the united states but you know
people like
people like cass sunstein say people
should be nudged rather than forced into
making those decisions and there's a lot
of behavioral economics behind it which
many on the left write off as centrist
nonsense but i think there's there's a
fair amount to be taken from it these
are really really important um uh topics
which have a lot a lot behind them uh
and i appreciate you calling in about it
thanks for taking the thanks uh thank
you for taking the question david my
pleasure there is dylan from
massachusetts
uh an important call on a number of
important issues
let's go next to sd
from dallas texas sd you're on the air
hi david thanks for taking my call again
pleasure uh so
about a couple months ago i forget
exactly when it was uh
i called in
basically
talking about how horrible the
gerrymandering was going to be that
all of these like red states were going
to break up the cities and whatnot and
to my surprise
it actually hasn't been going as poorly
as i've suspected
like
many have looked at this like i think
including um
i forget his name the guy from the
washington post he said it was basically
a wash at this point so
my question is that being said
would you can would you consider like
you know dumerism taking for granted
that the democrats are going to lose the
house and the senate for
concern trolling would you consider that
a soft form of voter suppression
your let me see if i understand you're
saying
to go around saying democrats are going
to lose it's a form of suppressing the
vote because if you convince democrats
they're going to lose they won't even
bother voting
yeah that's part of it yeah
yeah i mean you know this we've looked
at this on both sides there was a time
where it was like you know trump and
others saying they're going to rig it
don't even bother and then they would
kind of go back and forth and go no you
should vote in that those special senate
elections
i think that um it's unclear to me that
when people are told that they're going
to lose that they actually don't vote i
i think it's just an empirical question
and i haven't seen it studied if people
beli wrongly believe their side is
likely to lose are they actually less
likely to vote or do they become more
likely to vote i don't know the answer
it's something we could study and
probably get an answer to
yeah like we study so much the forms of
hard voter suppression yeah like when it
comes to strict voter id and it seems
like even that it's really indeterminate
uh like whether or not that actually has
as big an effect as many of us would say
it does yeah um but then again it seems
like the larger interest of the larger
factors like people's motivation to like
actually go out and vote which is why
i'm kind of concerned with i don't know
why i called it soft voter suppression
well the other thing is even in saying
we're gonna lose it's like you could be
saying we're gonna lose don't even
bother voting and you could be saying
we're gonna lose unless we all go out
and vote and those are two very
different things
yeah yeah i i agree
well i'm just kind of sensitive to like
uh like howas said over that nuts well
uh thank you for taking my call david my
pleasure my pleasure a good uh good
topic and glad to have the opportunity
to talk about it let's go next to mark
from los angeles mark you're on the air
hello can you help me yes i can
oh awesome
i can't believe i'm on the show again
yay
um i um i asked before i i called before
about stacey abrams and the whole thing
happened and i think was georgia
so what do you think first of all i have
like a couple maybe two or three
questions whatever i can get in um what
do you think is going to happen with you
know biden's like talking tough like he
really wants to perform the filibuster
and actually get us uh you know uh get
get the voting rights bill passed do you
think that's gonna actually happen
though is this more talk like a
reconciliation bill oh you know what i i
want to be optimistic about that i have
a really hard time believing it's gonna
happen because reforming the filibuster
you need all 50 senators and joe manchin
doesn't seem like he's going to go for
it and neither does kirsten cinema so i
it's feeling like it's just some
talk i don't know i want to be proven
wrong but
yeah but joe manchin kind of said like
oh he'd be open to to to making it a
talking phillips buster but do you think
he's just you know
pardon my language but you think he's
just bullshitting the most it was a
reconciliation bill the most recent
thing i saw from manchin is he said he'd
be open to making some mutual changes
to the filibuster which sounds like he's
saying mutual with republicans i don't i
don't really know
i'm just not sure but listen if you if
it's just an even money bet do they
change the filibuster i feel like they
don't
yeah yeah i'm feeling yeah i'm just
after the after relics reconciliation
bill i'm just prepping myself for
disappointment yeah anyway um also i
want to know why do you think people i i
work for a union okay and like literally
like
like almost 50 of the of my members are
conservative even though
republicans and conservatives were the
ones who put forward right-to-work laws
and remember when mitch mcconnell when
they were talking about reforming the
filibuster and mitch mcconnell made this
threat and he made he threatened to to
do two things one of them was what was
the other one oh yeah national uh uh
national uh voter id which is actually
in the uh the the voting rights bill now
it's just it's more a looser uh version
of voter id where you don't have to get
some id that you have to have a bunch of
paperwork and money to get yes and he
made national right to work law so
that's literally him saying a dream you
know idea for republicans and yet yet
you know like there are tons of union
members who vote for him i don't get it
it's uh it is bizarre and there's this
weird thing about unions where
it's not weird but it's a notable thing
for a very long time
um
unions
represented a mostly
democratic voting group they weren't
like progressives in the modern sense
but they were just kind of like
middle-class center-left democrats and
now
there's been a big move away from
union's ideologically
and there's a lot of people who are
vocally against the idea of unions but
they're still part of a union now some
of them would say i have to be in the
job i'm in i'd rather not i'd rather not
pay the dues but you have this weird
situation where you have republican
union members who love candidates that
are against everything unions stand for
but they're still in the union and some
would say i have no choice but there's
definitely a little bit of an
inconsistency there
yeah but it's it's ridiculous because
i'm a stagehand hand
in our union
we make way more money than the people
who are not union represented i mean
when we they are there are there are
union members stagehands with full-time
jobs who are making six figures and more
so they are crazy i mean so yeah there's
that let's see what else do i have to
say well listen we have so many people
waiting let's let's keep it to those two
questions i think those were good let's
go out on top you know what i mean okay
let's go on on on a positive note okay
well i love you david i i subscribe i
constantly watch you and i finally got
to call in again marcus thank you so
much great to hear from you have a great
one all right very good
uh okay wow wow let's go next to eduardo
from brooklyn new york
hi david how are you i'm doing well
uh thanks for taking my call um
i you know obviously watching
everything that's going on
i have like a more
sort of wide macro vision uh of things
that are going on and a question i have
for you is
is there
any sort of
entity or anybody that's kind of taking
tasks of like all these rubicons that
will keep crossing that we're not going
to be able to
come back from give me some what like
what examples do are you referring to i
mean just the you know
best example coming top of my head is uh
you know the idea of like
claiming anything that doesn't agree
with you as fake news and things like
that i think that's a rubicon that got
crossed
yeah i don't disagree with you that's
become i mean i think there's a couple
one is
the acceptable treatment of uh any media
you don't like
in this completely hostile way that
trump started with jim acosta and cnn
calling any news that's critical fake
news
questioning the results of any election
when you don't like the results you say
that the election was rigged that's sort
of a rubicon that i feel has been
crossed yeah i to your question i don't
see the republican party backing off of
those tactics anytime soon i think
they're here to stay
right but e
you know my my
question really is like are we keeping
track of those so that like maybe
if we
i don't know say cross three rubicons
you know like one will get through
because we didn't you know there's so
many going on at the same time i mean
listen we're trying to we're trying to
and i think you know one of the good
things that happened last week on the
anniversary of january 6th was a whole
bunch of people
um wrote articles saying the
insurrection and coup it's not really
over they're gonna keep trying it jimmy
carter wrote a piece and you know a
bunch of people known chomsky was
interviewed about it so i think there's
an effort being made to keep track but
it is really tough
no i i and and i appreciate like you
know people like yourself you know uh
fair and dollar more those guys you know
like they you know they
keep people to task i just worry that
like it just you know it's a part of
like more of an ecobook like echo box
than uh yeah
you know but uh david you know keep on
doing what you do and uh i appreciate
all your effort thank you so much and i
appreciate you calling in uh we're gonna
take some more calls but we'll first
take a very short break if you're
holding on to talk to me and you still
want to talk to me don't hang up we're
going to be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show let's go to dean from dallas texas
dean you're on the air save us please
dean
all right can you hear me yes i can
hi uh first time caller long time
listener um i wanted to ask
uh do you think with the ongoing
pandemic having a massive impact uh
mostly on the elderly when it comes to
fatalities
that there will be
a significant extension to social
security seeing as how you know more and
more people are buying in and
you know they won't be able to
to cash it to cash out i'm not sure i
know what you're talking about you're
will social security be extended what do
you mean
yeah like um
the estimations for when social security
runs out of money oh i see oh so are you
are you saying is the money gonna last
longer or are people gonna have to wait
longer before they can start getting
social security right right is the money
gonna last longer
for uh you know because it's projected
that people like me on the younger side
won't be able to even collect because
it'll long run out of money by then
listen though those predictions are
heavily disputed so i wouldn't even
necessarily start with that as the
expectation of where we are that that
there are many serious analyses done of
the social security trust fund which say
it it's it's not going to run out
there there may need to be a period
during which people pay in a little more
or during which they might get out a
little less or have to wait an extra
year some but the the it's gonna all run
out hypotheses my understanding is have
been pretty widely debunked um in terms
of the effect of covet on that i don't
know the answer to that it's a very good
question but i think it's it's something
that it has it's got to be studied by
experts in that field and i don't know
that we're going to have all the data
until we're really out of the pandemic
right right well thanks for taking my
call appreciate it my pleasure
appreciate the call yeah that's that's a
really interesting question
uh i wish i had an answer i wish i had
an answer but i don't
let's go next to jack from indianapolis
indiana jack you are on the air
uh hey david how are you i'm doing well
yeah so um
i've just kind of been looking at the
way things have been going in um in
america right now yeah and um
you know the thing about it is that can
get kind of depressing
um and i think like
you know why do i follow this stuff so
much if you know all i can do is vote i
mean
aside from that i also do some music
that
is about these issues like police
brutality and government corruption and
stuff like that but
i was curious as to if you had any um
recommendations as far as like uh i
think they called civic engagement
you're saying what can you do other than
voting is that more or less what you're
saying
basically yeah there are so many things
i mean listen first of all
with technology the way it is now
you can participate in essentially any
race you want to by phone banking and
fundraising remotely if that's what
you're interested in doing that that's
number one number two
really important to understand that you
don't have to attach your activism to
individuals you might attach your
activism excuse me to issues
there might be you know regardless of
who your senator is
at the local level where you live
you could figure out oh you know what
there's a conservation commission in my
city or town i'm going to get involved
in that or if you care about literacy
most libraries and library systems have
ways for you to get involved i think the
first thing is
we've got to kind of disabuse ourselves
of this notion that there aren't that
many different ways that that we can get
involved there's community radio and
community television where you can get
involved essentially at no cost
depending on where you live in most
parts of the country um
there there's really so much and so the
first it's almost like there's there's
too much and you've got to figure out do
i want to work locally or at the state
level do i want to work by helping a
candidate or do i want to work on an
issue what do i care about most
education the environment et cetera
there really is no shortage of ways to
get involved
okay
yeah that makes sense um what what
exactly is phone banking
bone banking is very simple you there's
now there's systems where let's say um
you know let's say it's john fetterman
versus mehmet oz in the pennsylvania
senate race and it's a few months from
now right it's the 2022 election even if
you don't live in pennsylvania
you can sign up to phone bank and
basically you can sit at your computer
and you'll get it'll pop up and it'll
say okay here is a believed democratic
voter call them ask them if they're
planning to vote um call and it's so so
you can it's basically all done through
software at this point and no matter
where you are you can start making phone
calls for any candidate you want most
candidates assuming that they're set up
with these phone banking systems
okay that makes sense yeah really easy
yeah i think that's about it thanks for
uh having me on my pleasure yeah
engagement so many ways to get involved
there's really no shortage no shortage
um it's almost an embarrassment of rich
of riches quite frankly
let's go next to
i believe is it pronounced vedant from
is it winnipeg i'm not even sure
yeah can you hear me yes i can
how are you doing mr pakman i'm doing
well
yeah so winnipeg we're just in manitoba
canada love it
yeah so um my question was about
how do you choose what to cover because
i'll preface this with i listen to a lot
of like the new media landscape a lot of
breaking points with crystal and sauger
kyle kalinski tyt stuff like that as
well as yourself
and i find that
um like for example tyt will focus a lot
on like donations from
big um
like companies into politicians and how
that runs the political landscape i've
noticed that you find it tend to focus a
little more on like january 6 stuff like
that and i was wondering what makes you
find that that's the most important
thing that you want to cover it's not
this is a beautiful question vedant how
old how old a guy are you by the way i
am 15. okay i had a feeling you were a
younger guy listen you are asking really
high-level questions here okay you oh
you i i think you have upper management
written all over you as we like to say
in the united states
here's some here's the bottom line
um i don't have any secret algorithm or
anything
about what i'm going to cover i get to
cover eight stories a day more or less
and basically what i think about is what
do i feel like talking about today
where do i have something to add
on a story
what does my audience what might my
audience be interested in hearing about
um and is it time sensitive and
newsworthy and if so i just kind of say
here's the eight things i want to talk
about today i have all these different
possibilities and i'm looking at you
know i have a list of journalists i
follow on twitter and i'm all sorts of
newsletters and it's basically just what
do i want to share with my audience
today that's really it the reason for me
talking about january 6th significantly
because you mentioned that
is
the right is trying to rewrite history
on what happened there i think it's an
incredibly
important sort of before and after event
that has kind of changed the direction
of what we thought the right was willing
to do or maybe thought they were not
willing to do
and i want to do everything i can to
remind people that really wasn't normal
we still haven't gotten a full
understanding of everything that
happened on that day so that's why like
in the last 10 days or so i've been
talking about it a lot to answer that
specifically
okay that makes a lot of sense and then
this one's just a little more of a fun
one but like i was wondering like what
do you think about canada have you been
up here if so like what places do you
visit i love canada i have to say
the overwhelming majority of my
experience is in montreal i've been to
montreal probably 20 times in my life i
grew up going there and i've been i've
been so many times i love it i've been
to toronto it had less charm but a
beautifully organized kind of
less european city if that makes sense
you know it's a different story i've
also been to ottawa once
i i i don't want to insult ottawa but i
remember very little about it it did not
uh inspire me in any real way
and i'm really i've never been to quebec
city but i would like to go as soon as
it's uh reasonable and safe but i i love
canada and in particular you know i'm a
big i love france and so going to quebec
i just enjoy it significantly i'm sure
i'm sure i went for the first time this
summer just to move my brother into
college and that was really nice oh okay
what mcgill
miguel yeah mcgill's great mcgill's
great that's uh that's fantastic well
listen um is the correct pronunciation
vedant
it's vedant they don't and what are the
origins of that name um so it means
eternal knowledge in sanskrit so my
family is originally from tamil nadu
which is the southernmost province of
india amazing amazing well listen i uh i
appreciate the call my friend
thank you so much have a great rest of
your day oh you do wow what a polite
young man folks what a polite young man
that is that is really something else
um
okay
let's try eric from cancun now eric
happy new year i want to i want you to
get right into your question because you
know we've struggled with that in the
past my friend go right into it what's
your question today
hi david i will read you something i
wrote in your reddit
it says i know if republicans can be
trusted in the part of maturity
if often than not they
didn't use cartoons as real world
examples also picking fights with
cartoon characters that might be because
republicans can either be envious or
intimidated at sesame street and have
higher moral levels than them let's not
forget that marjorie taylor green went
to portray the green new deal as a
scooby-doo monster and when fred was on
asking the monster the culprit was
communist and the incident of attack on
titan do you remember
wow eric i have no idea what you're
talking about did you just read
something or is that something you wrote
it's something i wrote in your discord
it's about republicans wanting to use
cartoons as real
examples for politics do you remember
when marjorie taylor green went to
portray the green new deal as a
scooby-doo monster i don't remember that
i don't remember that no
and they were using memes in the
in the senate floor
i remember memes on the senate floor yes
that i remember yeah
soon
and they weren't picking fights with dr
seuss and sesame street yes i remember
that
um
[Music]
and i can i don't think they would be
mature enough to
focus in real politics since they're
using cartoons as real world examples
i mean
some that would be the job of
politicians and actual cartoonists and
not in those whom we trust with the laws
that's an incredibly astute observation
eric eric how is the weather in cancun
now it's sunny it's a bit cold but i
like it in winter and
awesome
and
who do you think they would go after
next like disney or cartoon network
because he belonged to ted turner and he
made captain planet or my little pony
i'm not sure eric eric from cancun
always uh unblemished every phone call
is absolutely perfect i really
appreciate
uh hearing hearing from you
um wow that is really really something
else
let's go next to roland from vienna is
that vienna austria
that it is david can you hear me i can
hear you fine
perfect yes yes yes uh i agree with the
previous caller i don't think it's
because they um that's the only way they
can formulate their thoughts but the
republicans the right wing in general as
we have over here they speak the
language of the internet much better and
they know it they know to use it to
to fool their uh their listeners better
than uh the left bus no i think you're
right i think you're right
listen uh i called him once before and i
dropped an f-bomb i want to excuse
myself for that because you asked me the
question about whether i like
cappuccinos
[Laughter]
and i quoted i quoted jimmy from philly
it said f your cappuccino right so
which brings me to my first point i want
to congratulate for you for a piece you
brought out um in the summer
um with doctor and i'm blanking on his
name where you talked with the doctor
and with jimmy from phillip oh dr k dr
alok kenosha
that man is a hero i listen to some of
the other stuff he does with these kids
uh online is great
very revealing very very appealing about
the motivation for for where jimmy comes
from yeah
so that's it uh one point i want to make
two points the first one being
how putin seems to be um we know trump
loves them
we know uh fox news sides with them yes
are these guys aware that whenever
there's a mass shooting in russia
uh there's an assault rifle ban
they probably are not aware of that no
they should be putin is one of the
toughest guys on gun control because he
knows the only way to control the
population is when they don't have one
which they always say no so
uh it's it's really ridiculous to see
how they're falling in love with him
when uh in reality he's pushing a lot of
things that they're not comfortable with
well it's ridiculous for a lot of
reasons and you've just added one more
yeah and i see a lot of people asking
you to go back on joe rogan and to tell
him what's up and i think from a general
perspective i fully agree with that um
i've stopped listening to be honest i
was never a big fan anyway i'm in the
stand-up comedy so that was a good way
to get the news of the day in that field
but
uh he's hence the persona non grata in
my podcast feed wow
and specifically because this is
something that he always pushes so i'm
from austria i'm smack in the middle of
europe
we have socialized healthcare all the
countries around us
we're quite happy with it
and i always hear
um
from a lot of conservatives republicans
and all the mma guys on joe rogan
everyone's like oh if you're in if
you're in europe and you break your leg
you need to wait months to get it fixed
well yes if you if you want to get it
fixed socialized healthcare that that
pays for itself then you may you may be
on a waiting spot that's that's true but
i'm guessing you're you're not going to
need to wait months to be stabilized
from a broken leg right that seems crazy
no also
you know we do have a free market
healthcare system as well right in
parallel so nobody is stopping you from
dishing out the money for out of your
own pocket yeah you can even get private
health insurance you can get to private
hospitals you can get hospital rooms
that are like hotels if you want to pay
for it yes
and that's the big discrepancy if you
want to pay for it you can have
everything
but if you want to have it socialized if
you want to have it free
look if you can't afford it would you
rather wait for it a month to get the
hip replacement or would you rather not
get it you know of course of course and
uh
i i can really i can really feel myself
working up like i'm getting uh yeah
roland you're getting all worked up you
you need to go and have a cappuccino
uh not at this time of day but uh i'll
uh i'll have a nice smooth um
otherwise relaxing uh thing and
all right good roland from vienna you've
really said it all today thanks david
all right there it is rolling from
vienna wow
what a perfect way to cap off phone
calls this week i am sorry i can't ever
get to everyone
but i will try again when i see you back
here next week
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right everybody it's time for the
most awaited and sometimes most dreaded
moment of the week it's time for the
mailbag email us info davidpakman.com
uh spammers and people who abuse the
email uh just get auto-filtered into the
trash it's a sad thing but it does
happen some people email us every day
multiple times a day don't do it
nobody's going to read it it'll just get
you banned
let's just jump right in though because
there are messages that i would not
describe as being messages of peace and
love
user no bs wrote in
and said why don't you go back to
argentina
and complain about your own country and
start a show to divide it
you're a weak
pathetic
beta male
who sold his soul and show for a leftist
organization for money you're an perfect
example that's right you're an perfect
example of everything that is wrong with
the world today
satan
is your daddy
i take issue
with the fact
that we sold the show
for a leftist organization or to a
leftist organization for money
many have claimed we are soros funded
it's thinly veiled anti-semitism guys
people claim we're funded by the dnc i'm
not even a democrat the nc has never
never given us anything
um
just for once
putting the xenophobia of go back to
argentina aside for a moment just for
once i would love to see a single one of
these claims
backed up with even a scintilla
of data
i'm ready to hear it
if you've got it to present
next one this this is a bonus from
facebook i love this
this one actually has a big backstory
someone wrote to me and said cut your
show today and it's all entirely opinion
not news just fyi
now a lot of people write this
because
they
have such lack of media literacy
that they seem to think
i believe i do a news show now as all of
you know if you've been listening to the
show or watching it for any period of
time
you know that i accurately
characterize this program
uh as an opinion show
this is an opinion show and if any of
you have seen my sort of knowledge
pyramid where
if we want to be informed about the
world shows like mine should be
equivalent to the junk food they're more
entertainment
that hopefully gives you ideas and forms
who gets you thinking we need to have at
the bottom of our pyramid it's funny you
know it's sort of the opposite of of
like religious doctrine where it's like
we have the answers it's the opposite of
trump saying i alone can fix it my view
is
we should all have as a baseline
epistemology critical thinking
media literacy and philosophy that's our
baseline
that then allows us to go and read and
learn about history and political
science we take our knowledge of
knowledge
and we go and we study these areas
history economics all these different
things
the next
q quad piece of the pyramid
is
news reporting actual reports associated
press etc
and then after all that once you're well
versed in knowing how did i know how do
i come to know the things i believe
and
studying what has happened in the past
and economic theory and seeing what's
going on then you throw commentary and
opinion programs that you like on top of
that that's always been my position it's
almost like i'm trying to put myself out
of business but in any case it's funny
when someone writes in and goes your
program is not news it's opinion i
thought you should know that oh believe
me i know the fact that so many people
don't know is the problem we have in
this country
next email is from don don wrote in
about coveted deaths
don said dear david please refrain from
your weekly reports on notable
unvaccinated people dying from covid any
fool can point out that many fully
vaccinated people also have died from
cobit and your one-sided exuberance
makes you appear petty and thoughtless
um
i have never been exuberant about
unvaccinated people dying from coven
bring that to some other show don
because that's a garbage allegation
in every segment i say for me these
aren't funny segments these are not i
don't this isn't good so tell us with
someone else goes on to say you may not
care and perhaps you receive all
critique as being some political assault
but you really should take a moment and
think about how your well-earned
reputation as a reasonable commenter can
become sullied yours truly don well don
if you were making a criticism that was
connected to the facts that i'm
exuberant about these people dying that
would be one thing as i've said before
yes vaccinated people sometimes die your
likelihood of dying if you are fully
vaccinated is orders of magnitude lower
than if you are not and the reason that
we point out these stories is the
defiance with which some of these people
say i don't need to worry
only exists among the anti-vaxx the
people who go and get vaccinated
recognize even if i'm not likely to get
very sick i want the protection
why did i go and get my three doses
because i'm not likely to get very sick
but why chance it i wear my seat belt i
use winter tires
i would take the suit of armor if i walk
through a forest with arrows flying and
so the point here is
the defiance with which to the very end
they continue to spread anti-vaxx and
then they die and they are unvaccinated
i completely take issue with the
characterization from dawn
todd wrote in about the s last week we
looked at this segment where a uh an
anti-vaxx right winger model actress
type person
said that when she goes near vaccinated
people she has rectal bleeding
and i said that could be very serious
todd wrote in and said pacman i've
researched the strange anal bleeding the
poor woman is experiencing when around
vaccinated people my research concludes
it's a new form of stigmata if you wear
this on your show please don't play
pizzas here or we have kentucky fried
chicken in the background i don't know i
don't even know what that means but uh
yeah if i googled stigmata i didn't know
what it was apparently it's various
sores and bleeding
considered to be associated with some
kind of religious belief it's some kind
of punishment some
stigmata is like
if for sinning or something or satan
someone does it anyway it's uh yeah
given that many of these people are
christians you would think maybe they
would they would chalk it up to uh to
stigmata got another message alexa has
decided it doesn't like david pakman
greetings for the last few days asking
alexa to play the david pakman show the
latest episode
brings up techno music
i listened to it for a couple minutes
yesterday to make sure you hadn't
changed your opening music unless you're
opening with an extended cut i think the
alexa programming has gotten screwed up
i don't use slash have alexa if anybody
in the audience can replicate this if
you can get a video of asking alexa to
play the latest episode and it playing
techno please record it and send it to
info davidpakman.com we would really
like to see that that that sounds
absolutely hilarious
devin wrote in now by the way
for all the criticisms of david you're
an opinion show you're not a news show
um i always want to issue corrections
when they are warranted
devin corrected me about pcr tests let's
look at what devin said hello david sir
i was watching one of your recent videos
on youtube where you were discussing pcr
tests for covid and you mentioned that
the pcr tests detect viral proteins i
did say that devin writes this is
technically incorrect
coveted pcr tests detect the presence of
viral rna i know you pride yourself on
disseminating correct information i
figured you'd want to know you were
right devin i did want to know love the
show keep up the good work thank you
thank you
um
covet pcr detects the presence of viral
rna
i stand corrected and i bow at the altar
uh of the audience
and apologize
the rest of the analysis was correct in
terms of the meaning the diagnostic
value of a pcr test which has become
unfortunately the subject of yet more
conspiracy theories
lastly ryan wrote in and says sir david
david sur
have been a member almost as long as
i've been listening almost a year now
greatly appreciate your calm and honest
delivery of the daily topics keep doing
what you do we all appreciate it not all
you should see my inbox but i appreciate
the sentiment over the long weekend i
was listening to some of your old
interviews while i appreciate the
productive sane interviews i've got to
say the ones with quote religious people
are probably the most entertaining for
example the david manning interview
is just a total gem absolutely hilarious
i suggest the listeners check it out as
well thanks for your work happy new year
ryan thank you ryan yeah we keep sort of
going back and forth about the value of
doing the wacky interviews
a few months ago we did one with amanda
mackey and she was pretty cuckoo for
coco puffs it it does very well
but the reason i've gotten away from it
is partially it's less entertaining for
me like yes these people are bonkers
they're ignorant i get it
but they're so predictable
that i've been more going in the
direction of talking to
journalists writers investigators
doctors etc
um and number two i don't know i know
some people in the audience like it some
don't so i i'm as i've said before we'll
continue to sprinkle in the interviews
with the wacky people
but i've explained a little bit of why
i've sort of gotten away from it over
the last few years if you have a
question for me a comment a thought
whatever you can write into info
davidpakman.com remember that if you
want to get more show
every day you should sign up for a
membership at joinpacman.com producer
pat is back from his vacation he will be
back on the friday bonus show
as your regularly scheduled programming
has led you to expect we will see you on
the bonus show